bonsoir ça va alors bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle tout
le monde en parle c'est le cas de le
dire puisque votre deuxième roman rien
de grave
et l'événement littéraire de l'hiver ça
vous met dans quel état comme ça des 34
des ventes en tête des listes de
best-sellers sans télé c'est votre
première télé ce soir sans télévision
juste avec les critiques et le bouche à
oreille
vous êtes en tête des ventes ça vous ça
vous rassure vous fait plaisir
aucun camp tente alors on va d'abord se
débarrasser du côté pipolo ensuite on
parlera du du bouquin vous êtes né à
paris en 1974
vous êtes prénommé justin juliette
justin c'est votre père qui vous appelle
comme ça bernard henri lévy juliette
c'est votre mère isabelle doutreluigne
mannequin vedette des années 60
photographiée à l'époque par sarah moon
el mout newton qui deviendra une
militante acharnée de la cause de
féministes qui s'est aussi beaucoup
défoncé et qui vous confiez votre père
vous dit en parlant de bernard henri
lévy vite à la fois mon père et ma mère
ils comptent double est ce que vous
pouvez faire des réponses plus courte
parce que j'ai peur qu'on déborde un peu
donc quand à l'école on vous demande la
profession de votre père vous dit
philosophe et quand on vous dit c'est
quoi
vous dites c'est quelqu'un qui passe à
la télé je trouve ça assez génial
campillo vous demande pourquoi signer
lévis et pourquoi pas prendre un pseudo
vous dites on peut changer de nom quand
on s'appelle pivot on ne change pas de
nom quand on s'appelle lévis pour voir
ce qu'on stagne au bouton les juifs
ouais ouais vous auriez eu l'impression
de trahir votre judéité à l'adolescence
vous avez l'impression d'être un vilain
petit canard
et vous dites je suis encore aujourd'hui
dans le excusez moi
dans le excusez moi d'être ne pas
toujours être à la hauteur de plein de
choses way dans le excusez moi dans la
culpabilité en permanence pardon vous
avez l'air tendu crispé anxieuse
j'aime tellement la télévision est
partie coup d'envoi pas cet ennemi non
mais j'aime bien cette émission mais
cessé mais pour la regarder pas pour eux
ça va bien se passer c'est pour ça que
vous parlez vite c'est parce que c'est
l'idée d'excuser moi comme ça qui vous
fait parler pour pas embêter les gens
trop longtemps pourquoi pour me dépêcher
de te dire les choses que j'ai à dire
voilà donc adolescence cette impression
comme ça de très vilains petits canards
et puis c'est le grand amour vous tombé
raide dingue amoureuse de raphaël
enthoven fils de jean paul enthoven
éditeur et ami de votre père vous dites
on avait envie de faire un petit couple
on se disait nous on va y arriver
c'est vrai qu'on les parents on était
tous les deux on avait tous les deux des
parents divorcés on se disait que nous
on allait réussir là où j'avais échoué
voilà encore une enfant des paroles
version vous marier en 1996 et cinq ans
plus tard pour le passage à l'an 2000
vous partez en vacances à marrakech dans
la maison de votre père il y à là
arielle dombasle jean-paul antho veine
le père de votre mari avec sa maîtresse
du moment carla bruni et raphaël
enthoven donc va vous quitter pour elle
pour carla bruni le divorce sera
prononcé dans l'année voilà pour la
dimension je dirais pipolo et name
dropping de la faire l'oreille c'est la
littérature ça s'appelle rien de grave
et c'est publié chez stock c'est super
bien écrit avec plein de phrases
d'auteurs comme on aime et une flavour
françoise sagan dorothy parker
rien de grave ça veut dire quoi c'est
pas la fin du monde non plus c'est ça
ouais c'est une éthique c c'est comme ça
que c'est dans la vie rien de grave donc
quand les choses ne sont un tout petit
peu c'est une manière de ne pas alourdir
ce qui est déjà lourd il faut cesser un
impératif quoi c'est un indicatif un
impératif est un objet qui choisit pas
d'abord il françoise leclerc dans le
point à trouver une formule qui résume
assez bien le titre et votre façon de
faire raconter ces drames sans à faire
un drame c'est sa phrase alors le pitch
du bouquin louise et adrien cm donc
depuis la fin de l'adolescence
jusqu'au jour où adrien rencontre paul à
la jeune maîtresse de son père et la
peau la brise le coeur de louise en lui
volant adria alors au début louise et
adrien c'est l'amour ultra physio nalin
c'est là l'osmose total ça fait une
poursuite de l'enfant ce salon c'est
comme ça que les enfants aiment j'ai
l'impression qu'ils font dans l'autre il
n'existe que par l'autre enfin en tout
cas moi c'est ma manière d'aimer mais
c'est la manière de mon héroïne 6 mai r
j'aime toujours de la même manière je
sais c'est comme ça mais c'est un leurre
en même temps d'horreur à la mort fusion
et puis ces options le lean phrase
formidable c'est ce corps à deux têtes
cet amas de corps pour décrire l'amour
fusionnel vous dit deux imbéciles quand
on est fiers de leur bel amour ah non on
va leur balance et notre amour à la
gueule et on va leur montrer
on va vous montrer comment il était
heureux comme on s'aime n'est plus
heureux qu'on va réussir là où rien et
cela l'on raté là où
raphaël et pauline et mathilde et julien
tous les héros de la littérature qu'on
admirait nous on allait réussir
et puis peu la débarque dans votre vie à
tous les deux les deux héros il était
dans son bas c'est la musique ce soit
jalouse il me disait mais mon amour
c'est ma belle mère tu vas pas être
jalouse le mât belle-mère ça me faisait
rire mais quand même j'étais jalouse je
trouvais qu'elle faisait trop la
coquette elle était avec son père mais
je l'avais vu à la plage au café apte à
faire l'intéressant telle innocente
minauder draguer tous les hommes du
paysage au cas où vous êtes passionné
comme vous êtes séduisant
je la trouvais belle et dangereuse avec
ce visage immobile comme sculpté dans la
cire
quand elle sourit elle avait une sorte
de déplacement des eaux qui découvrait
ses dents tout pareil
taillez pareil je la trouvais belle et
bionic avec un regard de tueuse
quand j'avais 15 ans elle était déjà
même qu'un j'étais fasciné par ces
visages parfaits après j'ai appris
qu'ils étaient faux qu'elle l'avait
choisie sur un ordinateur avec son
chirurgien
alors voilà on va vous faire des
pommettes hautes comme ça en silicone
on raconte sur le nez et rajouter un peu
de menton pour l' équilibre du profil
très bien les yeux rien n'a changé pour
les yeux mais on peut opérer une légère
incisions sur les tentes l'histoire de
rehausser la ligne du sourcil qu'en
pensez vous quelques injections de botox
pour glacer l'ensemble pour les dons
vous verrai avec mon collègue ça me
plaisait mois dans le fond de décider
comme ça son visage je trouve ça classe
voilà c'est un roman dans c'est pas moi
j'ai pas visé j'en sais rien si si ça
correspond à la réalité ou pas moi c'est
pas çà mau c est quelque chose qui me
fascine la chirurgie esthétique en soit
c'est c'est cette espèce de vertige du
possible de choisir un visage sur un
ordinateur et de moi j'suis pas assez
courageuse pour ça le maximum c'est de
me faire teindre les cheveux en roux
embruns et sa part au shampooing enfin
au bout de trois chansons mais c'est il
ya une base réelle mais le
l'élaboration et littéraire et ça en
tout cas ses excuses merci adrien savez
les cheveux il s'était fait une drôle de
coiffure avec le shampooing des matchs
en l'air sur un côté ça me faisait rire
il m'a dit t'as pas être jaloux c'est un
milliard de fois plus belle qu'elle elle
est toute refaite tout si j'essaie
terminator cette fille tu sais ce
qu'elle m'a dit ah les reports quand je
suis la chercher avec papa et que j'ai
voulu l'aider à porter la valise
elle m'a dit merci j'ai besoin de
personne moi les hommes je les cache
tout de suite
et puis toute façon maintenant qu'avec
mon père c'est plus une femme c'est un
tabou c'est comme ça alors quelques
jours plus tard luiz croiser au pôle à
la piscine avait déjà avec adria mais
louise ne le sait pas hélas son sourire
terminator dites vous et son visage au
formol et là c'est terrible
elle dit n'importe quoi les gens
racontent n'importe quoi ils disent que
j'ai couché avec ton mari
vous êtes si mignons tous les deux
fenêtres ignoble pour détruire 30
bonheur non mais c'est ça moi c'est pas
tout à fait comme ça que ça s'est passé
dans ma vie j'ai quand même j'ai quand
même temps tu as mais un peu tout ça moi
samsam intéressait l'idée de ce fait
moderne voilà une femme qui arrive est
le père et qui repart lac le fils moi je
trouve ça avec eux c'est un matériel
romain s comment intéressant et
cliniquement intéressant quoi alors 150
pages plus tard luiz et à qui elle a eu
à faire c'est une méchante à pau là je
te le dis ce jour-là au café je t'aime
m10 est une [ __ ] une vraie fouteuse de
merde une qui chie dans les ventilateurs
et qui regarde l'effet que ça fait tu as
dû me gifler quand j'ai dit ça ou
protesté août énervé mais non tu as
juste tenté d'expliquer vexé mais
appelle non non tu te trompes à lui
bonne généreuse la lame élevé tu parles
une vraie garce une qui finira tout
vérolé comme madame de merteuil c'est ça
que j'ai dit tu ne m'as pas fait taire
et c'est ce qui m'a le plus scandalisé
moi j'ai toujours actif
stupéfaite enfin j'étais stupéfaite le
jour où j'ai compris que madeleine
chapsal les hommes et françoise giroud
avait été copine jusqu'au bout sa saveur
ça m'a sidéré elle déjeuné ensemble elle
elle faisait du shopping ensemble ça
j'ai du mal à comprendre
sur le plateau elle a dit ça soulage un
peu on n'était pas trop de deux pour ce
tempérament 7,7 rouerie dans les femmes
sont capables dans ces cas-là ça vous ça
vous détruit et vous mais l'homme en
même temps le personnage tu me
ressembles plus louise allez allez allez
roux est aussi un lecteur ouais je la
ménage pas non plus enfin je peux pas
des plus avantageuses avec ses
personnages
et puis on s'aperçoit qu'en fait tout
n'était pas si simple entre entre louise
et adrien avant même la rencontre avec
paula puisque adrien avait demandé à
luis d'avorter sous prétexte qu'ils
n'étaient pas encore faits pour avoir un
enfant demandé d'avorter ils ont décidé
ensemble d'avorter parce que c'était pas
le moment encore ouais donc il y avait
quand même déjà des figures dans le
cristal quoi mais bien sûr l'enfant dit
vous aurez s'étend maintenant il
s'appellerait aurélien il aurait sept
ans elle regrette louise ça quand on me
redresse en est malheureux de foi mais
non elle regrette pas je sens qu'on va
bien rigoler ce soir et je sais pas
pourquoi une bonne des compétences et la
louise va s'accrocher aux amphétamines
après 7,7 avortement vous voulez lire ou
je lis parce qu'en fait ce qui est
intéressant à vivre c'est de les lire
c'était de raconter ouais c'est ça c'est
difficile de commenter son propre roman
aussi ouais c'est après l'avortement que
je me suis vraiment mis à croire qu'il
me manquait quelque chose pas à ces
femmes pas assez adulte pas assez regard
de tueuse pas assez bien pour avoir un
enfant avec lui pas la hauteur passe et
où je me suis senti tout à coup la
superbe comme une chenille recalés
examen papillon et c'est comme ça qu'un
jour en fouillant dans les tiroirs du
bureau de mon père je suis tombé sur ces
vitamines pour le cerveau je savais
qu'il en prenait parfois pour travailler
pour rester éveillé finir ses livres je
savais que ça le rendait nerveux
concentré irascible rapide
j'avais toujours su qu'elle était là
dans la caverne d'ali papa mais ça ne
m'intéressait pas plus que ça je passais
devant sans les voir lui-même d'ailleurs
n'en parler jamais sauf avec ses copains
écrivain quand ils s'échangeaient leurs
recettes et leurs dosage alors que là je
me suis dit c'est génial c'est peut-être
ça la solution je n'aurai qu'à les avoir
partout tout le temps avec moi ces
petites pilules magiques les
premièrement je serai brillante malines
passionnante et deuxièmement ce sera un
peu de papa en moi ce sera comme s'ils
étaient avec moi on sera deux on est
forcément plus fort à deux car ça
m'aidera être à la hauteur
il faut bien ça pour être digne de rien
c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
donc la cedh intel sur vector captagon
et puis la drogue c'est toujours pareil
au début on en prend pour être bien le
cac prenant ne prendront pas être mal
donc ça se termine assez mal en cure de
désintox chaco des bulles les
amphétamines louve le monde
au début c'est extraordinaire comme
elles se sont intelligentes et vivent
alors on lit plus elle est pas mal à
l'aise comme l'âge de ce fait en ce
moment elle est là je réagirais infonie
tonnerre de dieu sur deux plateaux ce
serait merveilleux mais met en effet au
bout de quelques mois c'est
c'est tout à fait pareil d'abord c'est
ça la rend malade comme un chien ensuite
aller s'est passé pas si grave en soi ça
va ça pas de l'héroïne non plus c'est
pas mais elle empruntait dos tellement
massive que ça lui donne juste des
nausées des tremblements de la rampe
elle a de plus en plus de mal à cacher
son entourage à son mari à son père ah
c'est à tout le monde que qu'elle a
besoin de ça pour se lever le matin et
qu'elle a besoin de somnifères pour
s'endormir et que qu'elle a de plus en
plus de mal d'ailleurs à trouver des
médecins qui parce qu'elle trouve
fascinant déjà trouvé les médecins qui
acceptent de lui de lui prescrire des
choses comme ça monte ça devient de plus
en plus compliqué et puis ensuite à la
main tellement envie d'arrêter non plus
et de redevenir la gentille petite
louise davanture rougis qui comme moi
maintenant
voilà ça va ça va et puis c'est la
rupture
tu t'attendais à quoi je lui ai dit tu
crois que ça va être facile d'un petit
et tu crois que je vais te laisser faire
comme ça j'ai lancé le cadre par terre
le verre s'est brisé
mais comme ce n'était pas assez j'ai
bondi du lit et j'ai déchiré la photo
celle qu'il prétendait tant aimé la
photo de nous deux ans marié beau et
légèrement ridicule
il y avait tant de monde qu'on ne
connaissait pas notre mariage qu'on est
parti avant la fin il ya des supers
phrase d'auteur je fais dit merci c'est
gentil
il faut avoir confiance en lui
vous allez
vous avez écrit cette phrase aussi après
après la rupture si c'est magnifique
j'ai perdu les larmes comme d'autres la
vue et la parole elle peut plus pleurer
l'enterrement de sa grand mère elle
n'arrive pas à pleurer
ensuite elle a beaucoup de mal donc à
trouver effectivement un garçon qui lui
convient depuis qu adrien est parti il
ya eu 5 baiser trois amants je crois et
la rencontre le dénommé pablo alors là
c'est l'inversé du tout l'amour
fusionnel là c'est beaucoup plus adulte
disons je n'ai rien à lui donner je
n'attends rien non plus de lui après la
dispute à l'interdît définitivement les
mots d'amour c'est difficile de
réapprendre à aimer après c'est comme
une grande brûlée pardon c'est comme si
comme grace et dramatique quoi c'est
d'une violence inouïe un chagrin d'amour
en même temps c'est c'est vrai que le
tout réapprendre un do ré apprendre à
rire à s'amuser là est légère être
gentil avec elle avec les autres elle
doit est là elle est tout vide quoi et
tout est là plus qu'une envie c'était de
se rouler en boule est ce décès voilà
ensuite louise retombe sur adrien jours
sur le thème soyons amis non mais
rencontrent par hasard par hasard dans
un café et c'est fou d'ailleurs ccc
saccades plus terrible dans l'amour
c'est pas quand ça s'arrête on sait pas
quand on est rompu ou couteau rond quand
on équité ou larguées ou jetés ou mises
à la poubelle ou effacée par la liberté
de l'autre ce qui est terrible c'est
quand tout à coup on se réveille un
matin on cligne des yeux et on n'aime
plus l'amour voilà on aime plus et ça
quand elle rencontre adrian un café ils
ennuient l'ennui et ça c'est ça c'est
assez violent aussi comment j'ai pu être
amoureuse de lui comment s'est mis sa
jeune et tout ça j'aimerais qu'on soit
mais juste amis décident en sa annonce
je réponds ça veut dire quoi être amis
quand on sait tenté mais ça n'existe pas
ce glissement là c'est même immoral de
passer de ça ça c'est hors de question
tu n'es pas d'accord tu argumentes tu
dit paul à es6 ex
elle les voit tout le temps ses ex j'ai
envie de répondre qu'elle ne peut pas
faire autrement vu qu'elle a couché avec
la terre entière c'est de les renvoyer
pas assez accès ne verrez personne mais
c'est vrai que louise de temps en temps
le bastonner
mais je te dis juste qu'elle ne les
achètent pas tous aimé comme nous on
sait mais tu dis c'est vrai mais je ne
suis pas juste une connaissance je ne
suis pas quelqu'un que tu croises par
hasard et avec qui tu vas prendre un
café moi je tuerai pour toi et même je
me tuerai pour tous
voilà donc comme je disais en commençant
peu importe que vous soyez la fille de
bernard henri lévy vous êtes un écrivain
le mirail la littérature c'est que elle
sublime tout elle transcende tout quoi
qu'il vous arrive dans la vie pour en
faire un livre c'est vrai ça sert à ça
aussi c'est et puis surtout ça sert
ouais enfin on n'a pas souvent la
maîtrise de sa vie quoi on a
l'impression que vous échappe pour faire
moi en tout cas j'ai l'impression
qu'elle m'échapper alors que j'ai
l'entière maîtrise de mes textes ça
c'est je peux choisir chaque répétition
chaque virgule et c'est eux c'est un
sentiment de toute puissance quand même
ça c'est formidable et puis c'est ouais
c'est bien quand on vit trop près des
choses surtout quand on est myope comme
ça et quand on sort d'un chagrin et
qu'on n'a que des éléments épars
éparpillés une charpy de choses tout à
combler c'est comme une régénération on
transforme le désordre en ordre avec un
une cohérence une finalité avec un début
un milieu et une fin et si on veut en
éclats tous enfin c'est un bon devait
maîtresse de vouloir et annonce la
réapproprient croire
pourquoi de sa françoise la littérature
transforme tout sublime tout finalement
oui je crois
vous l'avez prouvé le voting à mon petit
niveau je ferais que je suis ressorti de
ce livre comme apaisée donc je peux
comprendre que l'écriture soit quelque
chose qui puisse reconstruire une
personnalité mieux faire accepter ce qui
vous arrive comprend différemment et
puis surtout moi j'ai l'impression de ne
pas voir enfin j'ai pas écrit les choses
telles que je les voyais mais maintenant
je les vois telles que je les ai écrites
mais cécilia y avait quand même une
différence mais du moins monstrueuse que
le personnage qui me ressemblent dans le
livre allez allez quand même c'est quand
même une
c'est quand même c'est gentil ouais
c'est une méchante sens comment ça va
maintenant ça va bien ça va bien mais
surtout ça comme ça allait déjà bien
quand j'ai commencé à écrire le roman
parce que quand j'ai enfin quand quand
j'étais au sortir de ce chagrin d'amour
j'étais j'aurais pas pu écrire trois
phrases normal c'était j'ai commencé à
écrire quand justement j'ai géré appris
à aimer et quand j'ai rencontré un
garçon qui marais qui m'a donné envie de
ne plus me protéger autant il a dit
belle du seigneur c'est fini faut
arrêter les seniors voilà je suis pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu